those with Morton also made another
promise about how she will govern if
elected in a recent blog post she said
that as president shall appoint a
cabinet that quote reflects the full
diversity of America included having at
least 50% of cabinet positions filled by
women and non-binary people what exactly
is a non-binary person does America have
enough non-binary people to staff half a
cabinet and by the way more to the point
how is being non-binary a qualification
to run a federal agency Dave Rubin host
the Rubin report on YouTube he joins us
from Ravel these mysteries do you thanks
what you're coming up that's kind of the
core question what is being non-binary
have to do with running a federal agency
well first off Tucker this is the first
time I've ever been brought in as an EIN
non-binary expert so I appreciate that
look ask what it means but yes it does
it doesn't even matter suffice to say
that all of this is exactly what's wrong
with almost every progressive idea
that's put out there like canceling all
student debt you then hurt the people
who paid off their debt or who acted
responsibility right hiring 50% women or
non-binary or minorities or this color
or that color it all kind of sounds
right but here's the catch and this
happens with every progressive idea you
just have to think about it for about
three seconds and then once you think
about it you realize oh well if we're
gonna have diversity hires of this type
or that type well that means you
intentionally must discriminate against
someone else by the basis of their
gender or sexuality or skin color
now the reason Elizabeth Warren doesn't
care is because she thinks she can hold
together some sort of coalition of
basically non white Christian people so
she can always sort of stick it to them
something to that effect and I think
it's a really poor strategy and we just
have to show people the the one idea
that works and that has always worked in
America if you work hard and you're a
good person nobody cares whether you're
non-binary whether you're binary whether
you're a man or a woman you were here in
LA I did your show last week and I met
your staff in LA and guess what Tucker
you're a good man you had black people
working for you and white people and I
met women and men and nobody cared
nobody cared can you do your job if you
can do your job
I have a small business myself we'll
hire you if you can do your job and it's
work kind of well for you know a long
time I just wonder as a political matter
what the market for this is I mean apart
from like you know 27 people on Twitter
is it's a country really crying out for
this kind of bean-counting no it's not
crying out for it I think that much of
the left almost all of the left has been
captured by woke ISM this can this idea
that all of these are supposedly
oppressed groups because most of them
are not really oppressed can somehow
come together and and somehow free
everybody from the evil patriarchy not
only is it not true but I think you're
actually making a great point about 27
people on Twitter so much of it is just
driven by social media hysteria real
adults and especially real business
people and real people who want to
accomplish real goals they don't care
about this stuff I never meet anyone
whether I'm doing my show or whether I'm
doing business behind it that really
cares about these things I'm hiring an
associate producer right now think how
absolutely absurd it would be if I said
that that person has to be a specific
gender or a specific skin color or a
specific sexual identification that
would be prejudice and and nobody is for
this except for this what I would say is
an increasingly small group of far-left
progressives i think that i think that's
right just hire the best people oh okay
great to see you thank you so much for
that if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell